[Music]
all right welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want [ __ ] joe you're back
in jiu jitsu
yeah i think it's been 25 years since i
did
something like this on a regular 25
years
well when we when we did it
i thought we're the same when i first
learned
it was judo that's why i've learned all
my foundation
and i did it for like two years as a kid
from like sixth grade to seventh or
something
that stuff's important dude like getting
in young and having that muscle memory
when we trained
that was like about a year or less yeah
i don't think we did that much
and then i just took a huge break after
that
and then uh for some reason i was like
nick i want to go
he goes go buy a ghee so i was like okay
and i got one oh that's why it was in
your your ig store yeah either
which one did you get i got black [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah you got it always go
black the blackie looks the best with
the white ball
i know right i was like i wanna
accessorize because then it's white on
white you kind of look like a [ __ ]
but then when you get a black belt yeah
then the black on the white looks good
and if you wear blue i think you're a
teacher for some reason
yeah kind of yeah that's the teacher's
gui yeah
i feel like the ones who wear blue are
like the punching bags they're just like
demos
you know like gummy demos the blue ones
remind me of olympics
yeah cause like i think in judo one
wears blue and one wears white or
something like that
because you can tell like clearly what
the opponents are
yeah yeah who's on top of it you wore a
blue one in your tournament right no in
addition you lost
didn't you guys have barbell geese yeah
we got them custom made so we thought it
would be funny to
sign up for a jiu jitsu tournament
without ever training that's so good
i did see one worst idea ever bro don't
ever do it it was it was hey but he got
first place
so that was that's the wow that's the
funny part so that's the funny part
and i did all this work for nothing so
we signed up
i signed up for my weight class and
since some of the weight classes are in
portuguese
like i didn't really understand how to
read it they're not they
are dude because you you [ __ ] me up
you didn't even know so we're like oh
[ __ ]
you're supposed to be like this weight
class and i'm like wait i gotta be
that weight class with the key on and
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm like two pounds
overweight
so we got trash bags my [ __ ] coach
here and his coach
had me like running like three miles
trying to sweat the weight off
you could sweat two pounds off in an
hour yeah yeah so we swap
you could do like five pounds so we
sweat all the weight off i ran like
three miles
my [ __ ] yeah get on the scale made way
boo yeah
go to look at the bracket and there's
literally no opponent
and i'm like but also though you win
because of no challengers
was that he read the [ __ ] he told us
the wrong weight and we're like all
right well you're not at this weight so
you have to cut
yeah so then he did the weight cut and
as we're walking up
one of our other buddies who's in his
age he's in the same weight class but
different age
he told me what way he was and i was
like wait so i looked at the website
and i saw the weight division and he
didn't even need to cut weight
because he's in portuguese i don't know
what the [ __ ] it wasn't portuguese but
like are the numbers the same no because
there's like no
no no i'll say like [ __ ] what is the
word like anyo's medio
weight class like medio heavy heavy oh
all i want to know is do you have a
trophy as big as your body that just
from
from showing up to this do you really
have a menace is first place on it dude
that's
you could be a first place jiu jitsu
winner if you just
gamify everything and figure out whose
weight class is not gonna show up
who's not gonna show up which region
isn't gonna have somebody world champion
bro
doesn't that mean i should get a blue
belt if i hit the podium my first mute
you
know
you know for some coaches yeah i podium
you should put that on your ig
oh and oh did they have a ceremony where
they hated you this [ __ ] medal
yeah take a picture bro i'm on the
podium
there's no one next to me and they put
the [ __ ] thing i'm like
yup they're like winner of the master
division medium heavy
bart quan did you at least go out and
fight yourself
and go so i actually had a chance to
fight someone so there's
uh what they do is if you're if you're
in an empty bracket and someone else is
in an empty bracket in their division
they'll go like hey you guys want to go
after it but the other guy was like 140.
so the other guy so they asked the other
guy they're like hey are you down and
then he was like
nah i'm good and it's okay so he won as
well you got first place in it yeah
so much honor there dude it's so crazy
they both get medals
at the same time though usually they
don't like make exceptions like that
if you if there's no one in your weight
class they won't usually ask
another weight class to step up and
compete he probably would have kicked my
ass
before striker for some reason they were
like [ __ ] him
and the guy that he was going to compete
against was like 140 pounds
this guy how much did you weigh like 190
well i cut down to 190. yeah
194. 194. usually that's a pretty big
gap but he has four strikes
i had zero stripes the fact that they
were even like thinking about it
but he's 140. zero strikes for 50 pounds
is the difference
yeah yeah that's my favorite experience
though was the acai bowls yeah the acai
bowls are good over there bro
you had jiu jitsu they're different he
was telling me he was like dude
the acai bowls at these brazilian events
are next level i'm like different
and i had them i'm like why is acai a
brazilian thing yeah it's a big i guess
oh yeah
oh what's so good about it because i've
had acai bowls and they're like whatever
you all kind of taste the same to me so
the ones no they're good ones
there's some really good ones the ones
you get at the the jitsu tournaments
they're the sorbet
yo the sword it's [ __ ] ice cream
that's why it's so goddamn good
the other ones you get they put it in a
blender and it's like a smoothie bowl
it's like you don't want to like
eat a smoothie out of a smoothie
[Laughter]
can
guys putting relish on hot dogs and [ __ ]
bro people literally pay money just to
go there
to not compete with anybody that's so
funny it was a big tournament huh there
was like four matches going on at the
same time like crowds full of people
like
it was better produced than like the
last fight in cobra kai
there's like way more people we could we
could argue about that
i think they definitely spent all their
money in the first two episodes so bar
kwon is a [ __ ] jiu jitsu world
champion
i want to see that on your credit yeah
first of all
can you send me a picture of that i have
to see it yeah yeah yeah people were
like great job bart i knew you could do
it he's like yeah man everyone's a bunch
of [ __ ]
that's what i said i wrote i didn't run
the caption i won first place i'm like
you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] he's on my
next sport
because no one showed up retiring
undefeated
dude too easy they're too intimidated by
bart
they're like ah we can't show up to this
one i don't know that tournament was the
biggest [ __ ] show i've ever
been a part of that's [ __ ] hilarious
though imagine your very first official
competition you're like preparing for it
you're ready
and you win by just no competition
that's why
that's what we're going to do for joe
we're going to get joe and you just
you're next bro we have to do that i
want to be
[ __ ] up though wait what
marco [ __ ] up he had to weigh in no i
don't want to
prepare and just not get anything sign
me up for a free first place i'll take
it
and the acai bowl though better come
with the brazilian side i'll go for the
acai bowl
for the sword batch they have good
brazilian food after the tournament
yeah we all ate and he didn't do
anything it was great nadeem had a good
match though he
he did good yeah or what happened the
night before he was watching all kinds
of jiu jitsu on youtube oh [ __ ]
but he also wrestled in high school he
has like some sort of grappling bass
but his first match like he got like a
textbook armbar
and he actually won that it was crazy
i'm like what that was tight
he just did it and i was like [ __ ] all
right i think there's like three or four
people
in his division and uh he actually
earned his second place
yeah wow yeah she earned it second place
yeah actually because he beat that
guy so those two they have to meet and
then so when him and the other guy meet
the other guy was just clearly
one guy knows jiu jitsu the other guy
doesn't know how tall is nadine
you're like 510. the guy he competed
against was like
six foot five oh [ __ ] well the dam's
almost like
300 pounds yeah no but that guy was also
that
he was also that heavy but [ __ ] six
foot five
so the team had to like go through it to
get a second place podium and you were
just like up there
you have to fight two people yeah yeah
he fought two people and was second and
all you had to do was put like a trash
bag on her right now
that's jiu-jitsu and it's prime easy man
didn't
give a speech after he he's just like
man i just watched youtube dude
[ __ ] awesome dad can you imagine
being beat by a guy that just watched
youtube the night before
i hope i didn't tell them that after
that's what i hope happens to all sports
dude i can't wait it's all the logan
paul [ __ ] right we're just let's i'm
gonna go fight the top boxer and if he
wins it destroys boxing forever i can't
[ __ ]
and they dedicated like 20 years of
their life and here comes this youtuber
that comes in and [ __ ] you up
and then they talk about how easy it is
after that's i can't [ __ ] win
i could actually watch this video on the
barbell brigade channel we documented
the whole thing
it was fun it's pretty nice yeah yeah
everybody was mad at you guys for doing
that don't mind at us
because they were like you this is a
disgrace to you i can't even take the
pictures of jiu-jitsu
yeah but at the same time of course you
are it's very clear it's very clear
we're
[ __ ] right because we're trying to
have fun we're trying to have fun like i
don't want to be a dude you said next
sport
what are you talking about i'm not
trying to be a douche you guys are
[ __ ]
you guys are whack hey suck it this is
too easy
i'm trying to be respectful though
today's video is brought to you by
human which is hvmn
and it starts for health via modern
nutrition
and it's a pretty cool company because i
am really excited about
this whole thing especially because i've
been on this whole
keto diet thing right so like keto is
basically
consuming a lot of fats and the fat is
helping you burn fat because you're not
eating carbs
and there's a whole science behind but i
want to get too into that basically
it's the kind of diet that i'm in right
now and the problem with it
or at least my own problem with it is
trying to find things
that are tasty or you know good or
or it works because a lot of these
nutrition bars or whatever
tend to have a lot of sugar and the diet
is
no sugar no no carbohydrates so
we teamed up with human and they they
sent me a bunch of bars that are keto
bars
and they had some pretty delicious ones
from savory
like uh saltier ones and spicier ones
they have spicy chocolate
they had like uh chocolate chip which is
the sweeter kind
and the cool thing about it is it's
super small so i could take it on my
hikes and all this stuff
and if i get super hungry i just pop it
in my mouth
and boom like energy i yeah it it
satisfies the hunger and i think it's
pretty awesome
yeah yeah what i like about the company
is they give stuff uh the crazy stuff
mainly for people that are doing keto
but also people are just trying to
improve their
their diet and their lifestyle so most
of the products that you find
are lower in sugar like their mct oil
their keto bars
even their keto collagen powder
so they have all kinds of stuff to help
improve your diet improve your health
help you sleep better
help you feel better and all that and
right now for our listeners
if you go to hvmn.com off the record
you get an additional 10 off whatever
you want to buy
so go out there shop around go oh maybe
i could add this into my coffee or
here's some snacks i can take around
school around my job just go to hvmn.com
off the record to get another 10
off and you could use this mixer for the
coconut coconut oil that
that you can mix the powders and stuff
and
you can drink that it's pretty awesome
thank you very much and then you can
avoid a super sugary latte that's going
to probably make you gain weight and you
can be
wow yeah we're going to get joe in a
tournament bro you know so that jake
paul's of jiu-jitsu
and we're assisting bro we assisted on
this
i want to learn some basics first joe
did really good for his first day this
guy's very scrappy this guy do you have
a goal with this
i don't know i just get [ __ ] up yeah
yeah i like how i feel
like i just like uh feeling um
like um someone's trying to kill me and
i'm trying to kill them
four times throughout the day while
we're training joe turns to me and he
goes
i feel like a kid again man i feel like
a kid again and he just kept saying that
he was he loved it it was great
i did uh this one in junior high and i
had a lot of fun with my friends doing
it and i did that yeah
that was yeah i think that was my first
love for martial arts because i did
karate before that but i didn't like it
that much
i just want to know when he doesn't feel
like a kid true
very true i would be interested dude i
tapped myself out trying to choke
somebody
yeah he did because it was so hard man
he has a thick [ __ ] neck and i was
just like i can't do this anymore man
[ __ ]
and i was like i tap was that alex
it was kenny kenny got a big old head
this big chinese dude
and he was trying to choke him out but
he's tough though it was cool because he
let me
um pretty much almost make him pass out
multiple times so i can get a good choke
in and i can know what that feels like
oh are you are you the only one here who
doesn't have martial arts experience
uh do you have martial arts experience
uh i took taekwondo as a kid but
i i can still get my ass beat purple
ball taekwondo
jewelry karate let's go anybody want to
go let's go i would love to see that
that's pretty hot you should have a jk
news i got forms i got my forms down and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
all that [ __ ] i remember
you don't get purple vote for nothing no
you don't you actually have to work for
that one
yeah you got to pay monthly fees you got
to play all for you got to show up bro
i had to beat up a five-year-old i was
also five
how many belts do jiu-jitsu have white
blue
purple brown and black so five what's
that like
red and white one it's like three to
four stripes in between though yeah
if you take each step but if you're like
some phenom yeah
like this guy we went two belt two
striped purple to like brown straight to
brown
no not a couple of stripes have fallen
off my belt so you should have had brown
i always figured it was like the the
master of the studio that was like if
they were like greedy and like wanted
your money they'll just like invent like
600 different belt variations
that kind of does happen in low-key the
original belt system was just
white to black it's white brown black
white brown black right
it is a lot easier to get
promoted nowadays that's what i'm saying
like i remember when i first started
taekwondo because i did it for like
seven years maybe
and i remember my first year there was
maybe like seven belts right
yeah and then by the time i like
finished there was like
like so many belt combinations or like
the stripe in between the colors so it
wasn't just like blue it was like blue
with the white stripes yeah if you go to
a martial arts supply store you're like
what the [ __ ] is this like rainbow belt
any combination of two different colors
you could find that's when i got out
when i was like seven years old i was
like they're just giving these things
away now dude i'm i
said okay steve was a man he's like next
sport dude
[ __ ] this mcdojo it's not the same
i had to work my ass off to get my
purple i'm watching these five-year-olds
come and get purple and i'm seven now
and i'm like no no no
as i said it dude the standards have
been diluted bro
you know why you don't want a belt from
a studio like that say [ __ ] that how do
you get
like higher belts like what do what do
you have to know it usually depends on
the uh
criteria of the instructor so whatever
they kind of see as fit whatever it's
very subjective
i think it's basically you have to
memorize the dance
i swear to god this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah so i got the second degree black
belt baby
hey but low-key though dancers make very
good martial artists across the board i
mean i learned martial arts first so i
actually give credit to my dancing to my
martial arts ability
see there it is but that's helped with
memory like choreo like body awareness
and also technique the body awareness is
so key
especially from a dancer all the people
that i've trained that happened to be
dancers
they actually got really good really
quick and i got good at dancing because
my taekwondo was dancing
it's the forums is choreographed forms
is everything but yeah forms is
literally everything it's how you
do combat it's exams to hip-hop and how
you sell it too like how you like
put your body into it that's the other
thing if your school didn't [ __ ] do
choreo to mortal kombat
then you weren't real karate if you
didn't have a ninja turtles poster like
from the movies
like in your dojo you were in a fake
dojo do you know that kendra's first
performance ever we danced in mortal
kombat really
really oh
yeah i even contemplated the new techno
remix at the end of the new movie but
then the
new movie kind of sucked but it was also
really good but also
it's time that's exactly how i felt too
yeah it was like kind of whack but it
was like it was actually really bad but
the killing was like really cool
yeah the song was a letdown dude do you
guys have a belt system for your dad's
school
we should now you should we should but
you know
[ __ ] done with the dance schools
i'm out dude [ __ ] lost that one
[Laughter]
well what about in china aren't they
there aren't their dance schools there
no at the end of the day you know i
think dance is such like
a subjective like experience for for
especially for kids you know what i mean
like it's all encouragement it's not
like tests like
i hope you're better than that person
and it's like competitive don't asian
parents want you to do that though
absolutely why do i upgrade this [ __ ]
they want you to but it's not exactly
like we need a criteria
i think the the power of dance and or at
least the weirdness of it is
people want to like move together it's
like forms in martial arts but like
usually you think that's kind of like
oxymoronic because the martial arts kind
of like
naturally thinking about like fighting
or self defense right dance is not about
that it's like the weird human
experience of like moving in unison
especially in choreography with other
people so
you want to like work together and build
teamwork
versus trying to like excel beyond but
obviously that culture is still there
but you put a classroom together and
everybody's still trying to outdo each
other and get to the front line you know
what i mean but
it's a it's a more synchronized swimming
kind of
experience i looked up like the actual
definitions of
of the built-in jiu jitsu and as a
subjective as it is
they do have some sort of like standard
so it's supposed to be
uh once you get your blue belt that's
supposed to mean you can tap out a
untrade person that's heavier than you
that's what blue belt means and then
purple but means you
mastered every single technique in jiu
jitsu and you understand it
brown belt means you can uh you start
understanding all those techniques and
you have
counters and traps for those techniques
so now you can bait people and then
black means you have counters to those
counters so you can set traps to
get them to so it's like double double
counter
and at the black belt level you're
supposed to be able to start inventing
your own stuff
interesting that's what they told us
they were like once you get the black
belt it's almost like you've just begun
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up
i do say that all the time that's
literally the end
dude or they go you know i just feel
like a white belt again you know it's
like all right but also
you know they're probably just saying
this to be humble or something yeah yeah
yeah but it is kind of the right
mentality but also
you don't have to say it anymore
everyone knows it you know you gotta say
it too much
i wanna be up on the podium though
having faked all this humble [ __ ] the
whole time and then i'm like
[ __ ] sick but you know it's funny
like the number one grappling guy in the
world who just destroys everybody
his like claim to fame is him talking
[ __ ] to everybody
right you're [ __ ] yeah you're [ __ ]
whack you're trash and he's like i had
to do all this [ __ ] just to make the
sport popular
and he's making the sport but he's not
really like that he's not really like
that but he
he [ __ ] with people and he's like
you're a [ __ ] you ain't [ __ ] you when
he just talks
it's entertainment it's wwe anybody who
does that constantly
is like that a bench to some degree you
can't you can't be like i'm not like
that but i do it for this and then i do
it for like 20 years that's true
you [ __ ] that's you also what happens
when you get martial arts and you mix it
with business though
in entertainment yeah yeah it's just
strictly martial arts is its own
practices but then that's boring as [ __ ]
it doesn't sell tickets yeah
so you mix it with business and then now
you have like this crazy personality
that you've got to bring into it
that's true because like mike tyson's uh
coach was saying
that when he invented that peekaboo
style he's like because boxing
should not only be effective but very
entertaining to watch
so he thought about entertainment along
with boxing versus like
you know if you watch mayweather i don't
think he's as ex exciting
most boring champions i've ever had i'll
say it to his face and i'll run away
[Laughter]
effective but is it exciting as tyson i
don't think we'll ever see a fighter
like that you know and the reason why
he's making all this money is because
he plays the [ __ ] [ __ ] like he
plays the guy that you want to see get
knocked out
but if he had a very entertaining style
like maybe like a canelo
he wouldn't have to do all that true
right so it's like a give and take right
yeah
so it really depends on entertainment
yeah what you're dealing with
like the mcgregor of the world right so
funny
he's probably one of the best trash
talkers like ever yeah and he's talking
to everybody
but he also is like knocking people out
but if he doesn't win
at a certain point in time like he's
kind of on a losing streak that his star
is actually still pretty bright which is
actually crazy but i think it just shows
the nature of the sport you know that's
why jake paul's draw is so crazy
yeah everyone wants to see him get
knocked out and he never loses
yet dude his own dad's like betting
against him he's like somebody lay this
[ __ ] out i should have years ago
you